Paradigmenwechsel auch was die
europäische Asylpolitik angeht hätte ihn
genau diese Naivität die Sie gerade
beschreiben die werfen viele genau ihrer
Partei vor allen Dingen vor und sagen
Sie haben da eigentlich diese
bundesrepublikanische Gesellschaft
überfordert dem sozusagen immer das
Ideal von humalität Menschlichkeit
hochgehalten wird nach dem Motto wir
haben die Pflicht jedem der zu uns kommt
zu helfen diese Politik ist jetzt an ein
Ende gekommen oder wir würden sie das
Beschreiben erstens war das nicht unsere
Politik unsere Politik war diejenigen
die bedroht sind und von Krieg fliehen
die bedürfen des Schutzes und wir
brauchen zusätzlich das werden wir am
Freitag verabschieden
einer Politik die geordnet und gezielt
Einwanderung in dieses Land organisiert
weil wir ökonomisch und demografisch auf
diese Einwanderung angebunden sind das
was völlig anderes als kommt mal her ihr
Lieben und der offenen Grenzen das ist
Verwaltung und daran hat sich im Übrigen
nichts geändert wie man am Freitag sehen
kann nämlich wir werden dieses Gesetz in
dieser Form so verabschieden sind das
erste Mal dass wir ein echtes
Einwanderungsgesetz mit einem
Punktesystem haben wie wir das in Kanada
und den USA Sie im Vorfeld und nicht nur
sie gesagt dass das geht so nicht das
können wir nicht dass das können wir so
nicht durchwinken kommt dieser Parteitag
und plötzlich ist Ruhe im Karton wir
haben Sie das gemacht ja das hat glaube
ich eine
sehr schwierige Situation für die Grünen
die nämlich damit unzufrieden war wie in
Brüssel durch die deutsche
Bundesregierung verhandelt wurden grüne
Außenministerin die Federführung hatte
schon das Innenministerium aber es war
eine gemeinsame abgestimmte Position der
Bundesregierung von CD von SPD und den
Grünen und diese Position hatte drei
Punkte beinhaltet nämlich erstens das
ist ein wirksam verteilmechanismus geben
soll zweitens das
es Regeln geben muss hinsichtlich des
transites durch entsprechende sogenannte
drittschneiden und drittens das Familien
mit Kindern nicht interniert werden
sollen das waren drei Kernpunkte auf die
sich die Bundesregierung verständigt hat
mit Zustimmung der Grünen und von diesen
drei Kernpunkten ist vielleicht ein
halber im Bereich der Verteilung real
realisiert worden und das hat extreme
Missstimmung ausgelöst am Ende hat dann
ein Beschluss gestanden für den
diejenigen die das verhandelt haben
akzeptieren muss dass es dort sehr
scharfe Kritik daran gab die andere
Seite aber akzeptieren muss dass diese
Entscheidung getroffen ist und nicht
rückholbar ist sie haben von dann was
Wettbewerb der Schäbigkeit gesprochen
sowas in der wir haben eine
Harmonisierung moralische Erklärung das
habe ich nicht gehört ich habe
gesprochen und zwar weil es muss man
klar haben es ist ein Fortschritt in
diesem Ding
dass wir jetzt ein europäische Regelung
haben dass wir dieses ein Stück
weggenommen haben aus der
Rechtsunsicherheit einzelner
nationalstation europäische Regelung
direkt gelten Wirken des europäisches
Recht diese Harmonisierung wieder was so
schön heißt hat aber auf einer
niedrigeren Niveau stattgefunden als wir
das in Deutschland praktizieren und das
habe ich mit dem Niveau der Schäbigkeit
gesagt ein Sonderparteitag kurz danach
gefordert weil sie gesagt haben die
Grünen das würde so
vermeidene weil ich viele Leute erlebt
haben und zwar sehr unterschiedlichen
Interessen innerhalb der Partei
das ist ein solchen sonderpartei gibt
weil ich weiß da kommt nichts raus und
deswegen habe ich mich sehr früh dafür
eingesetzt dass wir einen solchen
Kompromiss auf dem Partei dahin bekommen
dass die eine Seite akzeptiert dass die
Partei der Auffassung sei schlecht
verhandelt die andere Seite aber auch
akzeptieren muss das in einem
Verhandlungsprozess zwischen dem Rad
übrigens unter spanischer
Präsidentschaft mit dem Parlament nicht
mehr rauskommen kann als das Parlament
des fordert hat deswegen wollten sie
kein Parteitag deswegen haben sie davor
gewarnt da kommt nichts mehr weil sie
Angst hatten dass es Kavum macht oder
einfach weil nein doch drei Monate lang
uns öffentlich beschäftigt hätten mit
dem Thema wo am Ende nichts anderes bei
rausgekommen werden als jetzt auch
rausgekommen
heizungsgesetz ist eine andere Frage und
die würde ich auch anders einordnen und
dann würde ich am Ende ich rede darüber
ins Gesetz gucken was denn da drin steht
das wird gar nicht so schlecht werden
das heizungsgesetz
wo vorliegen also pardon aber den gibt
es heute noch nicht ja bewusst gesagt
wir machen das am Ende ich fand
interessant was Sie gesagt haben
abgestimmt in der Regierung weil es war
ja schon so also es gibt ein
abgestimmtes Konzept man geht nach
Brüssel in dem Fall nennt sich Weser in
enger Abstimmung mit anderen Lena
Werbung es ist aber klar wo man auf wen
man in Brüssel trifft also es ist nicht
mehr das Europa der offenen Grenzen
sondern es sind sehr harte
Verhandlungspartner die Deutschland oft
Naivität in der Asylpolitik vorwerfen
oder eigene Interessen verfolgen dann
gibt es am Ende einen auch vom Kanzler
befürworteten Kompromiss und bei Twitter
explodiert sozusagen die timelines der
Grünen der Fraktionsspitze die sich ein
selber shred und der eine geht danach
links und der andere nach rechts die
Fraktionsspitze war sich uneinig die
Parteispitze war sich uneinig dafür gab
es dann offenbar eine sehr gutes
partei-management vor diesem kleinen
Parteitag denn das hätte eine ampelkrise
auslösen können von der man nicht hätte
wissen können wie man sie einen dampft
die interessanterweise die CDU ja am
gleichen Tag auch einen großen einen
kleinen verteilter gehabt aber im großen
prima borium angekündigt im Nachhinein
muss man sagen ist es jetzt ein bisschen
sind die Diskussion anders
können Sie so nehmen aber natürlich hat
sich ja es wurde befriedet aber das hat
sie gesagt das Ergebnis im Antrag ist ja
haben wir beide uns auch hier schon mal
intensiver darüber unterhalten Asyl
Einwanderung offene Grenzen das ist doch
genauso grüne DNA wie atomausstellung
Entschuldigung
als jemand der 1993 als Landesminister
der Änderung des Grundgesetzes nicht
zugestimmt habe dass wir damals der
Auffassung schon damals nicht der
Auffassung sind wir brauchen offene
Grenzen wir müssen diejenigen die vor
Krieg und Verfolgung fliehen und das
werden auf diesem Globus leider mehr der
Uhren hatte er hat in der Woche wo wir
diesen Parteitag hatte neue Zahlen
vorgelegt dass die Zahl der flüchten
sind sich global verdoppelt hat und dann
bin ich auch an so einem Punkt Forderung
und Überforderung der Bevölkerung so ich
finde es nicht richtig der Bevölkerung
zu erzählen dass dieser Kompromiss
kurzfristig dazu führt dass die
Turnhalle um die Ecke wieder frei wird
erstens
[Musik]
dieser Kompromiss wenn er denn kommt am
Ende des Tages in drei Jahren Wirkung
haben und zweitens ist völlig offen wie
weit die rechts Wirklichkeit jetzt an
dieser Stelle dazu führt dass die
zunehmenden
Migrationsströme und fluchtströme in der
Welt nicht mehr nach Europa kommen da
habe ich ganz realpolitische Zweifel und
deswegen würde ich das die Bevölkerung
nicht widersprechen das ist nicht
versprechen das ist schlicht eine Lüge
also sie sagen das was jetzt sozusagen
politisch verbreitet wird also die jetzt
haben wir da Ordnung reingebracht dass
das wird jetzt anders ablaufen ich würde
ganz ruhig sagen
das wird gar nicht eintreten auch auch
deshalb nicht auch interessant ob das
stimmt das dass
alles das was da besprochen worden ist
nur für die ersten 30.000 sozusagen geht
nein es gibt eine Obergrenze in den
internierungen Gebieten in der Fiktion
der nicht einreichen von Thema
Internierungslager aber das sind also
ich kann das auch sachlich beschreiben
wir kommen Menschen kurz an die kommen
auf europäischen Grund und dann wird die
rechtsfiktion erhoben sie sind nicht in
Europa und damit sie da müssen sie da
bleiben man kann das sagen sie müssen da
bleiben man kann sagen sie sind in Haft
man kann sagen sie sind internieren aber
sie dürfen den Platz nicht verlassen
genau
zunächst auf 30.000 gemacht werden
30.000 nur so dieses ist das Verfahren
womit man einen Vorteil hat dass am Ende
jeder registriert wird das ist ja das
also 30.000 noch mal ganz kurz das sind
3,5 %. wäre richtig richtig EU-weit im
vergangenen Jahr mit der Perspektive
auch nach oben gehoben werden kann und
wir reden über 30.000 Menschen was
machen wir dann mit den ganzen anderen
mit den anderen
gesagt habe es wird nicht zu einer
kurzfristigen Verbesserung führen aber
was haben wir denn da ausgehandelt haben
wir den Leuten jetzt erzählt Frau
Münstermann das machen wir so da kommt
jetzt Ordnung rein und den Wahrheit geht
alles weiter gehabt kann es sein ja
gut das eine sind eine der wesentlichen
Kritiken von Eric Marquardt ja gut aber
er hatte primär andere Kritiken
nein aber Entschuldigung
was wie eigentlich haben was ja alles
regeln soll was noch nie und in den
letzten Jahren oder ähnlich funktioniert
hat also diesen Punkt sauber
rausarbeiten das ist doch also ist das
in Ordnung wenn man das politisch so
verkauft und sagt Frau Feser z.B
Innenminister und wir gehen jetzt hin
wir bringen jetzt Ordnung in dieses
historischer Durchbruch hat sie glaube
ich gesagt historische ein historischer
Durchbruch und lässt aber Weg vielleicht
hat sie auch irgendwo erwähnt aber so
richtig ich bin über diese Zahl
gestolpert dieser Tag in der
Vorbereitung auf diese Sendung und es
ist sehr interessante Zahl finde ich
30.000 Menschen betrifft 30.000
3,5% noch mal derer die wirklich um Asyl
gebeten haben vergangenen Jahr 30 mal 12
Wochen maximal Aufenthaltsdauer deswegen
können sie das sozusagen auch höher
rechnen aber ich gebe Ihnen ja recht
deswegen sage ich ist das unanständig
den Menschen zum Beispiel zu erzählen
die jetzt ihre Kinder lieber in
Sportunterricht sehen würden da würde
sich sehr schnell etwas ändern und wir
würden wirksame Maßnahmen machen um den
Zuschauern an dieser Stelle zu beenden
das ist nicht wahr deshalb was erzählen
wir denn den Leuten dann streuen wir den
Sand in die Augen oder Sie das sagen
weil ihre Partei sicher dann über etwas
fast zerlegt hätte was vielleicht nicht
bezahlen gelesen habe vielleicht ist das
der Grund warum das auf dem grünen
Parteitag alles so geräuschlos
durchgehenheit hat sich gar nichts
ändern dabei sind also die Zahl in
Deutschland ist ja auch deshalb so hoch
weil eben die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
in Deutschland sind
Ministerpräsidenten zum Beispiel ein
Herr Kretschmer in Sachsen der den
Leuten erzählt man muss mal endlich
dafür sorgen dass nicht mehr so viele
Leute hinkommen jetzt sagen sie ich
stimme Ihnen zu es ist die Tatsache die
Grund die Grundsituation ist dass wir
fast eine Million Menschen aus der
Ukraine aufgenommen haben ohne diese
ganzen Verfahren und da kommt eine
wachsende Zahl von Menschen die aus
kriegen wie Syrien ähnlichen wir haben
ja teilweise sehr hohe
anerkennungsrouten das ist übrigens die
Unterschied zu den 90er Jahren da wir
sehr niedrige anerkennungsquoten heute
haben wir in vielen Fällen sehr hohe
anerkennungsgrund wir erkennen an dass
die Menschen aus Not fliegt und er
verspricht dass diese Leute nicht mehr
kommen das halte ich schlicht unter
greifen für unredlich und
unverantwortlich weil es darauf führt am
Ende des sich die AFD hinstellt und sagt
er hat uns das versprochen hat es nicht
geliefert naja aber der andere Weg ist
auch nicht gut ne ich finde dann lieber
mit den Menschen ehrlich zu reden aber
was ist ehrlich z.B das ist nicht keine
es wird weiterhin in dieser Welt die
dermaßen fragil ist wo sich solche
Auseinandersetzung zuspitzen wird es
kein Autorität geringer werden von
Flüchtlingsströmen geben
verabschiedet sich aus dieser Welt und
versucht das zu ignorieren und die Decke
über den Kopf zu ziehen oder man sagt
man versucht damit verantwortlich
umzugehen
okay ganz kurz noch mal also der
ehrliche Satz wäre gewesen nicht ein
historischer Durchbruch sondern der
ehrliche Satz wäre gewesen leute es wird
sich nichts ändern
wir haben den Versuch gemacht ein
gescheitertes System ein bisschen zu
reparieren und dieser Versuch war nicht
besonders erfolgreich so weil noch dazu
kommt dass er auch interessant diese
30.000 die jetzt sozusagen nach einem
Schlüssel europaweit verteilt werden
können da können sich ja auch Länder wie
Ungarn oder so die können sich raus
kaufen die Polen das auch schon
angekündigt
wurden auch nicht zahlen okay noch
besser für 20.000 Euro
pro arme Menschen der kommt legst du auf
den Tisch zahlst du ein in die
eu-klassenkasse und dann bist du raus da
musst du dich nicht um den kümmern das
die Geschichte das ist die Geschichte
das ist doch Europa ist das gut
patrickin ist das gut gesagt wir hatten
drei Forderungen von denen ist eine eine
halb umgesetzt worden das ist die zur
Verteilung weil man sich vor der
Verteilung vorgekommen und alles andere
waren von den Verhandlungspositionen die
die Bundesregierung nicht die Grünen die
Grünen hätten ganz anderen noch
aufgeschrieben mit nach ihnen gegangen
wäre aber das was die Bundesregierung
geeint hatte was mit der
bundestagsfraktiker sind von drei
Forderungen eine halbe umgesetzt
sie sind heimlich freuen sie sich
eigentlich über das was da passiert ist
verstehen immer besser warum es auf
ihrem Parteitag keinen großen Knall
gegeben hat freue mich überhaupt nicht
kapiert habe was da wirklich passiert
ist dass die deutsche Bundesregierung
mit mehr Ergebnisse aus dieser
Geschichte rauskommt wenn das mehr
gewesen wäre hätten wir trotzdem die
Versprechung die von anderen gemacht
worden sind nicht erfüllen können okay
jetzt sind sie fiktiv wir haben gerade
Joe Biden gesehen sie können doch alles
werden in diesem Land der Team sie sind
jetzt in der nächsten Legislatur sind
sie wieder Innenminister
also das erste Mal sie sind wieder was
würden Sie machen an den Außengrenzen
was macht ein Außenminister Trittin in
dieser Situation ich könnte Ihnen das
jetzt auch vorspielen ihren eigenen
Landrat Herrn schärft der vor einiger
Zeit hier war weil sie ob sie das
gesehen haben
grüner Politiker ein sehr ehrenwerter
Mann
den man aber genau zu holen muss und der
sagt wissen Sie was wir hören einmal
kurz rein weil er das ganze Dilemma so
gut auf den Punkt bringt ja ein grüner
ja keine von der AFD ein grüner bitte
schön es ist doch nichts ethisch
verwerfliches daran dass wir eine
Kontrolle darüber haben wollen dass wir
wissen wollen wären die europäische hin
die Union hineinkommt was ich glaube das
realistischen umsetzbare Möglichkeit
wäre weil das natürlich nicht während
ich am Grenzzaun stehe und mit dem
Söllner spreche sage und der entscheidet
dann ja dann brauche ich aber dort
Aufenthaltszonen wo die Menschen dann
auch für mehrere Tage oder Wochen
bleiben können das ist ja nichts anderes
als was wir momentan mit staatlichen
Einrichtungen innerhalb Deutschlands
haben das muss ja am Ende nicht ein
einen in meinen Augen indiskutables
Verfahren sein dass ein Jahr dauert
entweder direkt an der EU Außengrenze
oder natürlich auch wenn wir mal eine
vernünftige belastbare Flüchtlingshilfe
haben vor Ort natürlich auch dann schon
in Krisenregionen
so der arme Herr Scherf ne der glaubt
jetzt dass das so kommt der glaubt er
hat jetzt das weiß ich glaube ich ein
Thema gelöst nein er hat ein steinig
raus an einem Punkt ganz zufrieden sein
die Verordnung die jetzt verabschiedet
worden ist heißt dass jeder Flüchtling
registriert werden soll das ist
europäisches rechtmäßig aber
Mitgliedstaaten die dagegen verstoßen
würden sozusagen gegen europäisches
Recht verstoßen sind am Ende auch
möglicherweise so oder Objekt von
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren der
Kommission also dem Punkt hat er schon
mal was bekommen was die Frage angeht
der Unterbringung in solchen Lagern oder
wie immer man das bezeichnen möchte
angeht so wird es das auch geben nur die
Vorstellung dass zum Beispiel in
Krisenländern da musste ich eben drüber
schmunzeln solche Einrichtungen
stattfinden betrieben werden können die
geht an der außenpolitischen Realität
und der Realität der Staaten wo die
Menschen herkommen schlicht und
ergreifend dran vorbei sie werden auf
dem nordafrikanischen Kontinent diese
Dinge nicht einrichten können wir ich
habe erhebliche Zweifel ob man auch
gerichtsfest also das heißt mit Blick
auf das was wir in der Europäischen
Menschenrechtskonvention und ähnlichem
gesagt haben zum Beispiel ein Land von
Libyen rede ich noch gar nicht ein Land
wie Tunesien wo der Präsident der gerade
ein institutionellen Putsch dort
durchgeführt hat und diese begleitet hat
mit Pogrom gegen Menschen aus subsahara
Afrika dass man den mal eben schlank zum
sicheren Herkunftsstaat erklären kann
damit man dann in den grenzlagern gar
nicht mehr prüft sondern nur nach sagt
ihr seid weil ihr durch Tunesien
gekommen seid sicher sehr Künstlern und
seid ihr in einem sicheren Drittstaat
gewesen der hätte dir schon Sicherheit
gehabt deswegen Verfahren offensichtlich
unbegründet das heißt sie als
Innenminister das das sozusagen das
Prinzip der sicheren Herkunftsländer
würden sie
tragen würden sie ausweiten oder würden
Sie sagen das lassen
wir reden nicht von sicheren
Herkunftsländer wir reden von sicheren
Drittstaaten das heißt wir reden von
Staats für sie kein Land wo sie sagen
würden da kann man sowas ich würde nach
der jüngsten Entwicklung die ich in
Tunesien erlebt habe und insbesondere
den Pogromen die da organisiert worden
sind gerade gegen Flüchtlinge Zweifel
haben ob sie vor Gericht ist durchsetzen
können dieses Land zu behaupten der
hätte jemand der aus Ghana oder Gambia
oder Nigeria kommt oder aus Eritrea
einen sicheren Aufenthalt gehabt
der tunesische
Präsident
war gerade da also ich habe das durchaus
zur Kenntnis genommen er hat mich aber
nicht danach gefragt was ich von Frau
Meloni hatte sondern danach ob ich das
finde ich halte und natürlich ist das
die Idee und ich halte diese Idee nicht
für besonders belastbar
das nochmal sie als Innenminister
was machen wir
gibt es für sie gibt es für sie irgendwo
eine Grenze wo sie sagen also wir wollen
Leuten gerne helfen aber irgendwann
kommen wir in einen Punkt an dem das
einfach nicht mehr funktioniert und das
Stichwort ist nicht Humanität sondern
ist irgendwann auch mal Funktionalität
oder Ordnung auch im Sinne von es ist ja
wir hatten einen anderen
grünen Landrat hier der der sagte pass
auf es ist völlig naiv zu glauben dass
es hier nur um ein Bett in irgendeinem
warmen Zimmer geht sondern es geht um
alles was danach noch kommt es geht um
Kitaplätze es geht um die Erzieherinnen
die wir dort gar nicht haben es geht
schlicht und ergreifend um Schulen es
geht um bezahlbaren Wohnraum es geht um
die 400.000 Wohnungen die wir uns
gegenseitig versprochen haben aber
trotzdem irgendwie nicht hinkriegen weil
uns die Facharbeiter dazu fehlen und so
weiter das heißt erkennbar kommt doch
dieses Land an eine schlicht logistische
Grenze es geht einfach nicht mehr was
machen wir sie als ich noch mal ich habe
vorhin bewusst gesagt ich bin für
Ordnung ist einer der Gründe warum zum
Beispiel wir sagen man muss besser
unterscheiden zwischen denjenigen die
aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen temporär
oder dauerhaft hier herkommen deswegen
machen wir ein Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz und diejenigen die
unmittelbar Schutz bedürfen müssen
Schutz haben diejenigen die keinen
Schutz haben die müssen wieder raus das
ist immer schon Bestandteil dieses
Asylverfahren nicht funktioniert und es
gibt Personenkreise von den wissen wir
dass wir sie nicht zurückschicken können
was hindert uns eigentlich daran diesen
einen Status zu geben die es uns erlaubt
beispielsweise die Kinder ordentlich zu
beschulen sie in eine entsprechende
Ausbildung zu bringen
wir haben zum Teil ein dringenden Bedarf
Menschen die eine
Bleibeperspektive hier haben aus welchen
Gründen auch immer aber sie werden nicht
zurückgehen den ermöglichen wir die
Aufnahme von Arbeit die ermöglichen wir
in den Arbeitsmarkt reinzubringen und
wir hören auf mit der Fiktion seht ihr
seid nur vorübergehend bin ganz kurz die
zitieren nur eine Statistik die Kollegen
vom Wall Street Journal haben das vor
einiger Zeit auch mal sauber dekliniert
folgende Situation wir haben
rekordeinwanderung auf der anderen Seite
Fachkräftemangel wir kriegen die Leute
nicht in den Arbeitsmarkt wir sind
unglaublich schlecht darin das zweite
was sie treiben ist die
Arbeitslosenstatistik kann man nachlesen
und überrepräsentiert in der
Kriminalitätsstatistik während ich das
sage weiß ich schon wieder dass es
möglicherweise Ärger gibt aber es ist
Fakt können wir nicht drumrum reden und
ich bin froh dass wir mittlerweile was
diese Dinge angeht in einer Situation
sind dass wir uns ein bisschen ehrlicher
machen aber wir müssen doch darüber
reden wie wir dieses Dilemma auflösen
wir lassen das seit so langer Zeit
laufen und es funktioniert nicht
interessant ist in den USA sind
Migranten in der arbeitsstadt
Arbeitslosenstatistik unterrepräsentiert
bei uns sind Sie überrepräsentiert warum
ist das so wir sind unfassbar schlecht
die Menschen in Arbeitsmarkt zu kriegen
ja jetzt bestätigen Sie mich und sie
werden jeden Polizeibeamten der in
Neukölln oder im Ruhrgebiet mit kleinen
Kriminalität beschäftigt es kann Ihnen
die Geschichte erzählen wie insbesondere
Menschen aus dem Libanon über zehn Jahre
durch Arbeitsverbote daran gehindert
wurden zu arbeiten und dann sich ihr
eigenes Business geschaffen haben in
dieser Form und ich finde wir müssen
aufhören mit dieser uns Politik sich
selbst zu belügen es gibt nicht die eine
Antwort auf diese Migration das ist ein
umfassende Frage ja etwas mit
Sozialpolitik mit Wirtschaftspolitik das
hat was mit Polizei zu tun das hat auch
was damit zu tun dass bestimmte Leute
nicht berechtigt sind hier zu sein aber
die einfache Antwort die sagt
wir sorgen dafür dass alle die formal
ausreisepflichtig sind wieder ausreißen
das hat uns ein Teil zum Beispiel dieser
Integrationsprobleme beschert die wir
heute haben weil wir das nämlich gesagt
haben und wo wir wissen dass wir sie
nicht ausweisen können und deswegen rate
ich dazu an dieser Stelle nicht zu
vereinfachen den Menschen nichts zu
versprechen wir stehen vor einer
riesigen Herausforderung in dieser
riesigen Herausforderung stehen auch
bestimmte Chancen aber wir werden uns
anstrengen müssen als Gesellschaft um
mit diesem Problem anders umzugehen als
das bisher der Fall gewesen ist nur das
schlanke versprechen wir lassen
niemanden mehr rein und die die einen
nicht gefestigten aus sondern die werden
wir durch eine permanente exakte
Abschiebepolitik wieder loswerden dieses
einfache Versprechen das mache ich mir
nicht zu eigen